so you have how many days left in the
campaign 13 13 14 okay yeah I think
that's why just tweeted that better girl
that was 14 but oh it ends is it like a
dream the morning or something which I
might as well be victim yet so you're
you're coming down the home stretch what
are some of the mistakes that you've
made and then what are some of the
things that worked that you know you'll
continue if you ever go back again um
I've been doing a lot of reading
people's recommendations and a lot of
people have said that you should email
your social friends before you start the
campaign and ask them to help you and I
think that's a really good idea and
something we didn't do right and oh like
we said before not having a lot of stuff
prepared beforehand just because of the
time crunch no we are under so we would
have loved to have had some video
updates sort of pre shot and edited and
ready to go so that we could just every
monday we do like a video from a
different person or whatever but so that
would that would be something next time
going into it will be a more time and do
you find that a lot of people get back
to you if you send emails okay it's
really surprising that no one gets back
to you so I don't know what that is
saying okay I'm change for my friends I
mean talking like newspapers trying to
get a newspaper ads you know you give
people ideas do you want you could do an
article about this you could do an
article about that crowdfunding local
girl the horror movie small movie 50
other things and there's a lot of news
in chica right so I don't need your
ideas for sorts but we've gone we've
gone inside and found someone who knows
someone so that we're trying not right
now
okay yeah I think I think having making
contacts with with media outlets
beforehand where that would have been
helpful yeah to try to sort of get some
media exposure lined up before the
campaign why and it's how many days
total we chose 3030 okay are you happy
with that amount or do wish you'd gone
um I believe Kickstarter when they say
longer is it better so and it's so
exhausting and such a huge process I
mean that 60-day campaign looks like a
nightmare to me so I couldn't imagine
it's a long time as it is a job and
there's no so much momentum they build I
mean we're it right in the middle right
now and we're definitely seeing our
slump in the middle that all Kickstarter
campaigns have you have a big in the
beginning of a big exciting shoot up and
then again at the end you have another
one so yeah
you